para el año 2050 se va a necesitar
producir un 70 más de los alimentos que
se están produciendo hoy en día para
abastecer la demanda mundial
no es difícil imaginarlos que si
seguimos produciendo y consumiendo de la
forma en la que lo hacemos la
contaminación de las aguas de los suelos
la deforestación van a ser problemas aún
mucho mayores pero hay un ro dato que es
importante tener en cuenta un tercio de
los alimentos que se producen se pierden
en algún punto de la cadena productiva
cada 100 kilos de alimentos que se
producen solo llegan a las personas
entre 60 y 70
los alimentos se pierden o se desechan
por razones involuntarias como puede
suceder durante la siembra la cosecha e
incluso el transporte pero también por
razones voluntarias cuando se toma la
decisión de tirar material materia prima
en lugar de procesarlo para alimentos
inventos lo que les quiero hablar hoy
porque tenemos que replantearnos y
pensar cómo estamos produciendo antes de
llegar al 2050
cuando se estudia en la facultad estos
temas de contaminación ambiental e
incluso bienestar animal no sean temas
que se incluyeran en ninguno de los
cursos es más hasta estaba mal visto por
los docentes que los estudiantes
tuviésemos inquietudes sobre estos temas
con mi amiga claudia a que yo conocí el
primer día de la facultad y con quien
hicimos toda la carrera de veterinaria
juntas esto nos preocupaba porque no me
calentaba un poco que la formación de un
profesional sobre todo de una carrera
con la orientación en biología se basa
únicamente en términos económicos como
rentabilidad y productividad y no se
tuviera una visión más amplia
hoy por suerte ha cambiado mucho y es
así como hay disciplinas que se dedican
a estos temas y en mayor o menor medida
se habla del impacto ambiental en casi
todas las carreras por supuesto los
cambios son mucho más lentos de lo que
quisiéramos o de lo que debería ser y
todavía hay mucho por hacer tenemos que
seguir visibilizando los temas de
impacto ambiental en todos los niveles
de la educación
hace 8 años que yo trabajo en las apoya
de agronomía de la universidad de
nacional de la pampa y junto con mi
grupo de trabajo con marion y con marcos
trabajamos de largas fueron hicimos una
red de trabajos en cooperación con
investigadores de otra universidad con
diez muy nicolás y con una escuela
secundaria tratamos que ha sido integrar
investigación desarrollo tecnológico y
educación ambiental
ahora bien ustedes estarán preguntando
qué es el lactosuero y por qué a
nosotros nos interesa el lar contuvieron
está en sus productos de la industria
quesera es lo que queda después de que
se produce el queso la leche se vuelca
en unas grandes tinas y se produce la
población de las castellanas que es la
principal pero no única proteína de la
leche
el resto el líquido que queda en lo que
llamamos lacto suero para producir un
kilo de queso se necesitan 10 litros de
leche y esto va a producir 9 litros de
lacto suero lo que sucede con el
lactosuero es que es más barato tirarlo
que producir un producto
y cuando digo tirarlos me estoy
refiriendo a lo que ven en este vídeo
esto está mostrando un desecho de un
alimento en forma voluntaria un desecho
de los recursos que se utilizaron para
producirlo y un impacto ambiental por la
concentración de lactosa que tiene la
procedieron se está contaminando los
agua por la contaminación de sales está
contaminando los suelos
solamente en sudamérica se producen 50
millones de litro de lactosuero por día
y casi todo se tira 50 millones de
litros por día
nosotros estos nos propusimos que algo
teníamos que hacer entonces lo primero
que pensamos tanto mario como yo tenemos
formación en biología molecular y lo
primero que se nos ocurrió en que
podíamos trabajar con las proteínas de
lacto suero
pero nos dimos cuenta que el problema
era mayor era más inmediato era urgente
y que entonces era mejor salir del
laboratorio y que lo que nos propusimos
es que tenemos que encontrar
alternativas para usar al acto fueron
muchos y simples nos dijimos
simples porque complejas que existen de
hecho en la persona se puede deshidratar
se puede purificar las proteínas incluso
te pueden verificar el agua pero como
toda esta tecnología es muy cara muy
pocos las pequeñas y medianas empresas
no tienen acceso no tienen posibilidad
de hacerlo y es por eso que lo tiran
y muchos porque una sola no va a
resolver el problema del volumen del que
estamos hablando
lo primero que hicimos utilizar el
lactosuero como medio de unión es un
medio de cultivo ideal para cualquier
microorganismo porque tiene proteínas
azúcar y grasa tiene todos los
macronutrientes y tiene vitaminas y
minerales nosotros lo usamos para
cultivar levaduras porque levaduras
porque las levaduras es un suplemento
proteico ideal para la venta de
cualquiera de personas o de animales lo
que hicimos entonces fue ultimado en el
laboratorio usamos la persona como medio
de cultivo
después lo mezclamos con alimentos s los
mismos de comer a terneros esto fue a
punto cero no votó nada hacerlo porque
las dos fueron es hoy en día un residuo
y nosotros con esto logramos un producto
con un valor agregado un producto
proteico que sirve para el suplemento de
las dietas y por un lado disminuimos el
impacto ambiental porque el líquido lo
que queda después del cultivo de las
levaduras tiene un poder contaminante
900 veces menor que el alto duero
estos resultados nosotros lo presentamos
en un seminario en la facultad donde no
creíamos que íbamos a tener una gran
audiencia porque hablar de temas muy
técnicos y vamos a hablar de
biorreactores y vamos a hablar de las
cuerdas de crecimiento de las
temperaturas sin embargo vino gente y
nos llamó la atención alguien que se
sentó en el fondo que nos miraba y
nosotros no conocíamos cuando terminamos
se acercó y nos contó que era profesora
de una escuela agrotécnica de un vuelo
de la palma de victórica que ellos
tienen una quesería y teniendo el
problema de qué hacer con el acto fueron
estuvimos hablando y fue amar yo me
acuerdo que fue la que se le ocurrió que
el músico podía sin desarrollar una
bebida usar el lactosuero como una
bebida sabíamos que en otros países como
en venezuela y colombia se usan el
agregado del acto fueron el problema de
usar el acto fueron solo como bebida es
que tiene mucha lactosa más lactosa
y esto puede generar algún tipo de
intolerancia
entonces no todo lo que hicimos fue
darle el apoyo técnico para que los
chicos pudieran químicamente transformar
la lactosa en azúcar simple y acatan de
ese grupo de los chicos con sus
profesoras entonces estuvieron
trabajando durante todo un cuatrimestre
en el desarrollo de esta bebida probaron
22 saborizantes sin ton colorantes hasta
que lograron una bebida que les gustó a
todos
de esta forma ellos estuvieron
trabajando aprendiendo a trabajar en el
laboratorio aprendiendo control de
calidad aprendiendo a hacer pruebas
sensoriales aprendido todo lo que
académicamente necesitaban aprender
cuando cuando toda esta experiencia
nosotros fuimos y tuvimos una charla con
ellos y lo que nosotros fue lo que dijo
uno de ellos que dijo que lo que más le
había gustado era haber podido
transformar lo que ellos veían como un
residuo con un proceso muy simple en un
alimento el actor bruce en un elemento
y no es un caso puntual ni regional que
estemos tirando los solamente la
provincia de la pampa se tienen 50.000
litros en el auto suelo por vida
esto nosotros tenemos que encontrar
alternativas simples porque complejas no
sirve tenemos que crear redes de trabajo
porque eso nos potencia a todos y
tenemos sobre todo que dejar de ver los
desechos agroindustriales como residuos
y encontrarles una alternativa de
producción
[Aplausos]
ah